en un vídeo anterior probamos que si
tenemos un círculo centrado en o y el
radio es ode biseca la cuerda hace aquí
está implícito que ave es igual a veces
aquí ya tenemos estos datos de que estos
segmentos son iguales
anterior probamos que de este segmento
de edad perpendicular
a esta cuerda
pero lo que quiere hacer en este vídeo
es lo opuesto si sabemos que el segmento
ode es el radio y es perpendicular a la
cuerda hace lo que quiero probar es que
lo vi seca o sea lo divide en dos partes
iguales en el primer caso asumimos que
el radio divide a la cuerda en dos y
después establecimos que era
perpendicular
ahora comenzamos a afirmando que es
perpendicular y queremos probar que lo
vi seca de la misma manera que en el
vídeo anterior usamos diferentes
triángulos aquí lo vamos a hacer también
como ayuda para nuestra demostración ya
que conocemos bastante acerca de
triángulos en este caso vamos a dibujar
unas líneas que nos ayudarán a construir
nuestros triángulos y estas líneas van a
ser un par de radios más del centro del
círculo a esta parte
y de este centro del círculo a esta otra
parte
estos son radios hemos agregado estos
segmentos o c&a que son radios y por lo
mismo tienen la misma longitud estos dos
miden lo mismo esto nos es útil y quizá
ya se hayan dado cuenta de hacia dónde
vamos
el triángulo voy a etiquetar este punto
de aquí en medio este punto lo vamos a
llamar m el triángulo formado por a m y
este le puse m porque tengo la esperanza
de que ese punto sea la mitad de este
segmento hacer
entonces el triángulo
a m o es un triángulo rectángulo
el segmento o a este segmento de acá es
la hipotenusa y también el triángulo c m
este de acá es un triángulo rectángulo
con la hipotenusa o c
y justo acabamos de mostrar que estás
hipotenusa de acá son iguales
ambos tienen ángulos rectos que
comparten el mismo segmento o m el cual
es claramente igual a sí mismo este
segmento es igual a sí mismo
en un vídeo anterior explicamos que lado
lado ángulo no es un postulado de
congruencia así que el postulado lado
lado ángulo no
implica
no implica
congruencia
lo que sí establecimos en ese vídeo es
que un ángulo recto un lado y una
hipotenusa si es un postulado
este es un h y esto es postulado
de congruencia
esto sí nos implica congruencia es decir
si tenemos un triángulo rectángulo de y
bien está r
tenemos un lado que es congruente este
lado del medio y tenemos que también la
hipotenusa es congruente entonces
nuestros triángulos serán congruentes si
vemos aquí pues tenemos dos triángulos
rectángulos
uno de sus lados es igual al otro del
otro triángulo y sus hipotenusa son
iguales por lo que r lh nos dice que el
triángulo formado por a m o por estos
vértices es congruente con el triángulo
formado por los vértices c m
por este postulado rl h
y si esos triángulos son congruentes
entonces todos los lados también lo son
como hacen esto podemos decir que gm
tiene un lado correspondiente con mc
este lado de acá es correspondiente con
este lado de acá
y sabemos qué
si son congruentes
el lado m
va a ser igual al lado mc que esto está
implicado por la congruencia y ya que
estos son iguales entonces comprobamos
que el segmento ode biseca o divide
justo a la mitad al segmento hace otra
manera de probar esto sin usar efe lh es
por medio del teorema de pitágoras
nosotros ya sabemos a dibujar estos dos
radios de aquí de hecho voy a separar
esto para que se note que es una
demostración diferente sabemos que el
segmento o el lado oa es igual a 12
o sea que son iguales porque son radios
y también
use para que se note bien también
sabemos que el lado m es igual a sí
mismo
m este segmento de en medio y sabemos
por el teorema de pitágoras que la suma
del cuadrado de los lados va a ser igual
al cuadrado de la hipotenusa así que a m
al cuadrado más o
m/m
al cuadrado va a ser igual al segmento
de nuestra hipotenusa al cuadrado
conocemos esto para el triángulo de la
izquierda este tengo lo de acá y ahora
vamos a hacer lo mismo para este
triángulo de la derecha
este tenemos que la suma de s m al
cuadrado más
m
al cuadrado debe ser igual al segmento
11 al cuadrado
y ya que sabemos que es igual a 12 yo
aquí puedo sustituir puedo sustituir de
éste en lugar de oponerse o ser y si
quitamos o m restamos o en ambos lados
de esta ecuación nos va a quedar que de
esta ecuación a m
al cuadrado va a ser igual a 12 al
cuadrado menos
m o m al cuadrado y hacemos lo mismo en
esta ecuación de aquí abajo nos va a
quedar
si restamos al cuadrado en ambos lados
de la ecuación nos va a quedar que se m
al cuadrado va a ser igual a o sea al
cuadrado menos o m al cuadrado
y vamos a obtener las raíces cuadradas o
las raíces principales tomando en cuenta
sólo las raíces positivas ya que nos
interesan longitudes positivas y no
longitudes negativas así que tomando las
raíces principales en ambos lados me va
a quedar
además sacó la raíz cuadrada de me quitó
esto y voy a tener la raíz cuadrada de
esta parte como les dije voy a tomar la
raíz principal
que va a ser la raíz positiva por las
distancias positivas y hago lo mismo
aquí abajo entonces quito esto de acá y
aquí voy a tener la raíz cuadrada de
estos elementos esas cantidades dentro
de las raíces cuadradas son iguales por
lo que a m
a ms de acá va a ser igual a c m c m por
lo tanto eso se ha dividido en la
circunferencia en dos partes iguales
si ustedes saben uno de los lados de dos
triángulos rectángulos congruentes
siempre podrán usar el teorema de
pitágoras para encontrar el tercer lado
ya que será restringido por los otros
dos lados al ser un triángulo rectángulo
ahora si ya estamos por completo seguros
que si ud es perpendicular a hace
seguro lo vi seca o lo divide en dos
partes iguales